when you find yourself looking to
someone to lean on who is that person
who who helps you out my wife is my rock
man
during this she was the one kind of
coaching me being like hey you know I
understand that this is not normal and I
know that you want to be on the road but
like you kind of have to look at the
positive side of this stuff too like
even though you can't Tori you are get
to spend triple the amount of time with
your family right yeah three little
girls do they have just like running
around like crazy I mean is it do they
make it easier or more difficult to
create when you're at home you know I
just think as a parent for these times
like you have to get super creative you
know I mean you got to just make up
games out of nowhere kids entertained
and um we've been watching a lot of
movies and getting outside quite a bit
and but it's been a blast I've never
been at home this much in ten years so
in that side of things it's been really
great to get put my kids to bed every
night and wake up with them and get to
hang out with him more than I would if I
was on the road yeah you said you've
been watching a lot of movies how many
times they made you watch Scoob so far
making sure this isn't a dream you're
supposed to pinch yourself we've watched
it twice today actually it's amazing
like you know all you gotta do is put a
song in a movie and your kids want to
watch that one over and over and over
and over
[Music]
no one whenever my kids see me on TV or
anything else that are like like 10 I
know yeah they do I hope that keeps me
cool up into their teenage years I'm
sure
are they fans of yours like are they
playing your songs all the time the
dancin to your music dude it's all they
listen to it like they make me not like
my records anymore
because that's all we listen to so but
they love listening to my tunes yeah and
so do his fans Thomas has scored his
15th number-one us single with beer
can't fix
[Music]
are you getting a lot of people reaching
out to you saying that beer can't fix
means a lot of them right now yeah boys
money because people are like man you
have two polar opposite songs out B
alight and beer can't fix but they both
kind of they both do their own thing you
know
so beer can taste kind of helps you'd be
like well you know what this I'm just
gonna take this on the chin and this is
what it is and be a light hopefully
helps you to to just to learn how to be
kindness in a world that's kind of dark
right now
with proceeds benefiting MusiCares kovat
19 relief fund the all-star
collaboration features the likes of Reba
McEntire Lady Antebellum hillary scott
and keith urban how did you get a hold
of all those people to hunger there well
I'll tell you it's a lot easier to get
people to feature on your song when
they're not busy uh-huh
you know when they're when they're sit
at home - they're kind of like begging
for people to be like hey call me I'll
do anything